>> AFTER RETURNING FROM HIS
QUICK TRIP TO SPACE, JEFF BEZOS
HAD 2 OF THE BIG SURPRISES IN
STORE FOR PEOPLE TODAY.
HE MADE CHARITABLE DONATIONS IN
THE AMOUNT OF $100 MILLION EACH
TO 2 PEOPLE, 2 FRIENDS OF THIS
PROGRAM, THAT THE MONEY IS TO
BE USED AS THEY SEE FIT.
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR VAN
JONES, AND CHEF JOSE ANDREAS
FOUNDER AND DRIVING FORCE
BEHIND WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN TO
SERVE MILLIONS OF MEALS TO
DISASTER SURVIVORS AROUND THE
GLOBE.
WE HAVE INTERVIEWED HIM FROM
HOUSTON AND SAN JUAN AND I
CAN'T REMEMBER HOW MANY OTHER
PLACES.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE DONE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK.
WE TALKED TO YOU EARLIER IN THE
DAY, YOU GOT THE CALL SATURDAY?
>> I WAS WALKING ON A PATH IN
THE PHONE RANG IT'S JEFF BEZOS
SAYING HE FELT WE NEEDED TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WAS GOING TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER ACROSS LINES AND HE
WANTED TO BE SUPPORTIVE.
HIS PARTNER SAID WE WANT TO
GIVE YOU $100 MILLION TO DO IT.
I LITERALLY LOST THE ABILITY TO
SPEAK.
>> BURYING THE LEAD?
>> YES.
WHEN DID YOU FIND OUT?
WE >> AROUND THE SAME TIME.
3 DAYS AGO.
HE WAS LIKE, WHAT CAN WE DO TO
START INVESTING?
AND HOW TO CHANGE THE WORLD FOR
THE BETTER?
HE TOLD ME I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THIS MONEY TO START FINDING
WAYS TO SAY THAT HUNGER,
FINALLY ONCE AND FOR ALL IS
GOING TO BE A PROBLEM OF THE
PAST.
WE NEED TO BE BOLD, THE MOMENT
TO BE BOLD IS NOW.
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT YOU
TODAY, BOTH OF YOU, BUT I
REMEMBER YOU IN HOUSTON, UNLIKE
AN EARLY SCOUTING MISSION TO
SEE WHAT YOUR ROLE COULD BE IN
DISASTERS, AND HE'S ALREADY
BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS AT THAT
POINT.
YOU GOT INVOLVED IN HAITI AND A
LOT OF PLACES.
TO SEE WHAT YOU HAVE CREATED
THUS FAR, AND TO THINK ABOUT
$100 MILLION COULD DO FOR YOU,
OR FOR OTHERS.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO WITH IT?
>> ON RELIEF AND EMERGENCIES, I
STILL CLAIM I'M AN EXPERT, I
KEEP GOING WITH THE TEAMS OF
WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN TO KEEP
LEARNING.
HOW CAN WE DO IT BETTER?
WHAT'S THIS HUNDRED MILLION CAN
DO IS MAKE EVERY DOLLAR
MULTIPLY, PLANTING THE SEEDS,
AND COMING WITH BETTER WAYS
WITH BOOTS ON THE GROUND, IN
EMERGENCIES TB NEXT TO THE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY NEED IT THE
MOST.
WHICH IS AFTER THE HURRICANE
THE FIRE THE TORNADO HITS BEING
NEXT TO THE PEOPLE NOW.
AND BEYOND THAT HOW WE ARE
GOING TO BE DOING THE
CONSTRUCTION TO MAKE SURE WE
THE MONEY WE PUT FORWARD IS NOT
THROWN INTO THE PROBLEM, BUT
INVESTED INTO THE SOLUTIONS.
AGAIN, WE CAN DO BETTER.
WE MUST DO BETTER, AND FOOD IS
A GREAT PATHWAY TO BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE.
>> ANYBODY WHO HAS SEEN ON CNN,
EVEN IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU DO OUTSIDE OF CNN, HAS
HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I FEEL EVERY TIME YOU'RE ON,
YOUR NAMING GROUPS I'VE NEVER
HEARD OF WHO ARE DOING WORK IN
SMALL COMMUNITIES AND BIG
COMMUNITIES.
DO YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO DO
AT THIS POINT?
>> WHAT I DO KNOW, I DON'T KNOW
--
I MEAN, WE JUST FOUND OUT.
>> YOU'LL HAVE A FEW PEOPLE
GIVING IDEAS?
>> WHAT I WANT TO SAY IS I'VE
BEEN A PART OF BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER ACROSS POLITICAL LINES,
TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON.
>> YOU'VE GOTTEN CRITICIZED FOR
THAT.
>> NOT BY PEOPLE WHO GOT OUT OF
PRISON.
22 BIPARTISAN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
BILLS IN THE PAST 3 YEARS IN
STATES LIKE GEORGIA AND
MISSISSIPPI, TOUGH PLACES WHERE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET RED AND
BLUE, BLACK, WHITE, BROWN
TOGETHER TO GET STUFF DONE.
I THINK JEFF BEZOS SAW THAT.
IF YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE
TOGETHER, MANY OF THESE
PROBLEMS CAN GET SOLVED.
THE KEY IS TO BELIEVE THAT
ORDINARY PEOPLE ARE A LOT OF
SMART IN THE FOLKS TO GET PAID
TO YELL AT EACH OTHER ON TV OR
IN WASHINGTON D.C..
AND TO EMPOWER THEM WITH THE
ABILITY TO SOLVE THEIR OWN
PROBLEMS.
>> THE AWARD HE'S NAMED IS
COURAGE AND CIVILITY AND IT'S
AN INTERESTING COMBINATION
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS
WHO PRETEND THEY HAVE COURAGE,
ON CABLE NEWS WHO ARE YELLING
AND SHOVING THEIR OPINIONS DOWN
PEOPLES THROATS AND TELLING
PEOPLE WHAT TO DO WHO TO VOTE
FOR HOW TO THINK, AND THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
LISTENING TO OTHER PEOPLES
IDEAS AND SEEING WHAT WORKS AND
TRYING TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AND THAT'S SOMETHING BOTH WE
HAVE ALWAYS DONE.
>> I ALWAYS SAY WE NEED TO
BUILD BIGGER TABLES, NOT HIRE
WALLS.
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PANDEMIC THAT
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO WANT TO
PITCH IN AND THE VOLUNTEERS, WE
PUT TOGETHER ALMOST 3000
RESTAURANTS TO TACKLE THE
ISSUES WE WERE FACING,
HOSPITALS THAT HAD NO FOOD,
SHELTERS.
WE GOT ALMOST A BILL FROM
CONGRESS CALLED THE FOOD ACT.
WE WERE ABLE TO BRING SENATOR
KAMALA HARRIS.
WE BROUGHT PEOPLE OUT OF BOTH
PARTIES TO BUILD A PRAGMATIC
SOLUTION.
IT WAS BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AND SOLVING A PROBLEM.
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
AMERICA WANTS TO SEE.
FOOD BRINGS AMERICA AND THE
WORLD TOGETHER.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
ENTITLED TO A PLATE OF FOOD.
FOOD IS A WAY WE CAN KEEP
BUILDING A BETTER AMERICA AND
BETTER TOMORROW.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
WATCHING TODAY, AMAZED,
ENCOURAGED, EXCITED ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
SOME WERE THINKING THIS MAN
COULD SPEND HIS MONEY AND OTHER
WAYS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING RIGHT NOW.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT IN YOUR
TALK TODAY WHEN YOU WERE NAMED
AS A RECIPIENT OF THIS.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU SAY
TO THOSE WHO SAY IS SPACE
EXPLORATION SOMETHING WE REALLY
NEED?
>> THE LAST TIME WE HAD THE
SPACE RACE WE GOT SOMETHING
CALLED SOLAR PANELS, WHICH MAY
END UP SAVING THE WORLD ITSELF.
I AM PRO INNOVATION.
ON PRO ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
I WANT EVERYONE TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO PLAY.
WHEN THIS GUY HAS LIFTED THE
CEILING OFF OF A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE'S DREAMS, SOMEONE IS
REACHING FOR THE HEAVENS, THERE
IS MORE HEAVEN TO REACH FOR.
WE SHOULD BE INSPIRED BY THAT.
YOU SEE HE IS ALSO INVESTING ON
THE GROUND.
IF BIPARTISAN CROSS RACIAL WORK
A 20,000 PEOPLE OUT OF FEDERAL
PRISONS, PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE WORKING TOGETHER AND
BRINGING PEOPLE HOME.
MORE PEOPLE WILL KNOW THAT IF
YOU DO HARD WORK, AND IF YOU
ARE KIND, YOU JUST MIGHT GET
HELP.
>> VAN JONES, CHEF JOSE ANDREAS,
THANK YOU BOTH.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS
LIFE-CHANGING?
>> YES.
>> IN MY CASE, I WON'T END
HUNGER TOMORROW WITH 100
MILLION, BUT THIS IS A WAY TO
START MAKING BOLD DECISIONS.
THE RECIPES OF THE FAST TO FEED
HUMANITY ARE NOT WORKING.
WE MUST CHANGE THE RECIPE TO
FIND BETTER WAYS WHERE
GOVERNMENTS, CITIZENS, PRIVATE
BUSINESS, TOGETHER, WE CAN
FINALLY ONCE AND FOR ALL MAKE
SOLUTIONS.
WE NEED TO STOP GIVING SPEECHES
AND PUT PEOPLE WITH BOOTS ON
TH